Now that we've talked about the slope and
intercept, I'm going to go back to these few lines.
What I'm doing here is printing out some performance metrics on both my
test data set and also my training data set just for a point of comparison.
Remember the test data set actually provides the numbers that we're
going to trust.
Let me go back over here.
In the next few videos we'll be talking pretty exhaustively about
the performance metrics that you can use to evaluate your regressions.
But let me give you a sneak preview here.
One performance metric that we'll talk about is something called r-squared.
And to make a long story short, the higher your r-squared is, the better.
R-squared has a maximum value of one.
So what we can do is we can ask for
this regression that we've made, how good is our r-squared.
And we want to be asking that question of our test data set.
If we ask it of
our training dating set we'll also get some interesting information, but
only by using the test data set can we be sensitive to things like over-fitting.
So when I go over here and I look at the values of my r-squared score for
my test data set, and then also my training data set for comparison,
I get a little bit of information about how well my regression is performing.
I said the maximum value is 1.0.
The maximum value for r-squared is 1.0.
So since I'm getting 0.81 on the test data set and
0.87 on the training data set, I'm actually not doing too badly.
So rather than talking about r-squared anymore, let's go back to the tablet and
we'll talk some more about the types of errors that you can have on regressions.
And how you can quantify them.
So you really understand what these numbers mean.